Time magazine proves you can't trust the
press political runs the worst story in
human history and Melania Don's a very
weird jacket i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
Oh many things to get to today first of
all want to mention that if you still
want tickets to our events in Dallas and
Phoenix coming up in August check those
out at Daley wired.com slash events
because the tickets are selling fast
we're almost sold out in Dallas and we
are approaching near sold-out in Phoenix
so go check that out also if you have
not been sleeping well the reason you've
not been sleeping well is not because of
all the problems in your life it's
because of your mattress and that's why
you need to speak with my friends over
at helix sleep they've developed a
mattress that is customized to your
specific height weight and sleep
preference so you can have the best
sleep of your life ok it's not just a
generic mattress it's something that is
made for you you go to helix sleep calm
you take their sleep quiz it asks you
questions like do you like to sleep on
your back or your side your stomach do
you like the mattress to be firm you
like it to be soft you like it heat
absorbance or do you like it breathable
and then they send it to you in a box
you unpack it inflates right in front of
you because it's foam you pop it on the
bed and you are good to go in 2018 helix
sleep has taken customized sleep to the
next level with the helix pillow they're
only pillows are fully adjustable so you
can achieve perfect comfort regardless
of sleep position or body type helix
sleep has thousands of five-star reviews
you get a hundred nights to try them out
as well so there's no risk involved to
go to helix sleep calm slash bed right
now you get up to 125 bucks toward your
mattress order that's helix sleep calm
slash Bend for 125 bucks off your
mattress order again helix sleep calm
slash men we have a helix sleep mattress
in our house it is just fantastic we
took the more expensive mattress moved
it out of the room replace it with a
helix sleep mattress they are just that
good helix sleep calm slash Ben and
you'll get up to 125 bucks off your
mattress order helix sleep calm slash
friends that slash pen to let them know
that we sent you alrighty so lot
happening today we begin with Time
magazine so you recall that Time
magazine put out a cover yesterday the
cover of their new magazine is all about
why Trump is an evil terrible person who
hates children because there's what Time
magazine does every other Time magazine
is some sort of nasty take on President
Trump sometimes merited most often not
so here was Time magazine's cover in
case you forget it was in fact a picture
of a little girl who's crying as her
mother stands there with Border Patrol
and then everything is erased and it
becomes read and then in front of her
you can see President Trump and then it
says welcome to America so it's a tiny
two-year-old kid screaming and crying
and president some kind of President
Trump kind of smugly grinning down at
her because he doesn't care about the
children
well well well it turns out that this
entire cover is a lie not only is the
cover wrong about President Trump's
policy which of course has been the
policy in the United States since a 2016
court's decision from the Ninth Circuit
Court of Appeals so dating all the way
back to the Obama administration kids
have been forcibly separated from
parents who are arrested for federal
charges it is also not true because this
girl was not even separated from her
mother so they took a picture of a
little girl and then they photoshopped
it in to a Allred cover with President
Trump in the foreground and it turns out
none of this is true the little girl is
from Honduras she was not separated from
her mother at all
she was crying because her mom was
crossing illegally into the United
States and about 11 p.m. and little girl
was tired and thirsty according to
Border Patrol
here's a Border Patrol agent explaining
to CBS what the actual story here was we
asked her to set the kit down in front
of her not away from em she was right in
front of her and so we can properly
search the mother so the kid immediately
started crying as he set it down I
personally went up to the mother and
asked her are you doing okay he's a kid
okay and she said yes she's tired I'm
thirsty it took less than two minutes as
soon as the search was finished she
immediately picked the girl up on the
girl immediately stopped crying okay
so the media took this photo and they
blew it up and they made it seem as
though the kid was crying because mommy
had just been trucked away to the Nazi
death camp by President Trump this is
what the media did they ran with this
story they ran with the picture they
didn't tell you the rest of the story by
the way the guy who's speaking there his
name is Carlos Ruiz so clearly this is a
white alt-right racist from the border
patrol who's talking about this
situation
hey here's Reuters reporting Reuters not
daily why a Reuters quote the Honduran
toddler pictured sobbing in a pink
jacket before US President Donald Trump
on an upcoming cover of Time magazine
was not separated from her mother at the
US border according to a man who says he
is the girl's father quote my daughter
has become a symbol of the separation of
children at the US border she may even
have touched president Trump's heart
Dennis Valera told Reuters in a
telephone interview the letter said the
little girl and her mother Sandra
Sanchez have been detained together in
the Texas border town of McGowan where
Sanchez has applied for asylum and they
were not separated after being detained
near the border Honduran Deputy Foreign
Minister Nellie Jerez confirmed Valera's
version of events well not only was this
kid not separated from mommy it turns
out that
mommy was falsely claiming asylum she
has not in fact a political dissident in
Honduras in fact she ran away from her
other three children in Honduras she
left them there with dad dad has a good
job mom was working they and yet all of
this was was passed around the internet
endlessly and we were told that this
time magazine cover was just
demonstrative of how America has gone
the wrong way about how everything is
falling apart our moral status has been
completely decimated it's been
completely decimated thanks to President
Trump and his evil and you see people on
the Left repeating this idiotic routine
odd ad nauseam so for example there is
this one woman who tweeted out one of
these stories that has now become
ubiquitous on Twitter where you asked
her five-year-old a wou question or the
you ask her $5 so this woman whose name
is Bethany Oakley she tweeted out I
asked my five-year-old if she wanted to
come to a protest with me this weekend
first of all the answer is always no
your five-year-old does not want to come
with you to a protest this weekend
because why would a five-year-old want
to go stand in the heat for some cause
they have no idea what it is
once I had explained what we were
protesting she looked at me with tears
in her eyes and said what if they take
me away to I don't know how to have
these conversations with my kids there's
a bethany oakley tweeted out and you see
this kind of stuff all over twitter all
the time this thing had 15,000 likes and
other 14,000 retweets because asking
woke five-year-olds about immigration
policy is the way we ought to make
immigration policy in the United States
I know that when I have a serious
question about health care I immediately
go to my four-year-old and I ask her to
break down Medicaid spending for me it's
it's it's a crucial element to know I
need to know what my four-year-old
thinks about the future of Social
Security but more than that I like to
lie to her it's my favorite thing just
like Bethany Oakley I like to lie to my
child I'd like to say honey if Social
Security isn't reformed by the time you
grow up to 30 you'll be living in a
deathly hellscape in the United States
in which small children are fed to dogs
and then when she cries then I say to
her honey I don't know how to have these
conversations with you I just don't now
here's the real way you have this
conversation with your kid your kid says
mommy are they going to take me away too
and you say no honey I didn't commit a
federal crime all right that's the
actual hey that conversation is the
separation of parentsí kids it ain't
happening unless of a federal crime has
been committed in this case the lady
claims asylum and she wasn't even
separated from the kid some lady falsely
claimed asylum
she wasn't separated from the kid she
didn't come up for political dissident
reasons and she wasn't mistreated by
Border Patrol so this story tells
exactly the reverse it tells exactly the
reverse of the story than the media
wanted to tell that the media ran with
it anyway because this is what they do
and then they wonder why we hate the
media they wonder why so many Americans
look at the media and say we can't trust
you they wonder why when President Trump
shouts CNN sucks and everybody starts
chanting along with him that people are
chanting that's not because of Trump
it's because the media have been fibbing
about stories like this for my entire
lifetime and it's not just with regard
to the immigration issue okay there's an
amazing story today that Hamas paid off
a woman who claimed that her baby was
dead okay during the Israeli an Israeli
tear gas attack okay this is story from
The Times of Israel this is how they how
corrupt the media are this is from The
Times of Israel a 20 year old
Palestinian indicted Thursday on terror
related charges told Israeli
investigators during his interrogation
that Hamas leader Yahya sin waar paid
his relatives who falsely tell the media
that his baby cousin died of tear gas
inhalation the story of baby Lila
gondor's death purportedly from inhaling
tear gas fired by Israel at the Gaza
border made headlines around the world
last month and intensified global
criticism of Israel's handling of Hamas
spurred violence at the fence on May
28th IDF forces arrested Mahmoud Omar
along with another member of Fatah armed
wing the al-aqsa Martyrs Brigades it's a
terrorist group after they attempted to
infiltrate into Israel and torsional
unmanned IDF post Omar had been acting
as the lookout the group did not manage
to carry out the attack as they came
under IDF fire during his questioning
umar told interrogators the details of
the planned attack and detailed his
involvement in other terror alert
activities the suspect also disclosed
that he was related to Lyla Ghandour the
eight month-old baby whose May 14th
death was originally reported to have
been caused by inhalation of tear gas
sprayed by Israeli forces at Gaza border
protestors the story of the baby's
purported death dominated global media
and it turns out that two weeks prior to
the arrest this guy was part of the
giant border riot and he said that Lyla
had died of a blood disease similar to
the one that took the life of the
deceased infants brother who succumb to
the condition at the same age in 2017
the entire media ran with the story that
Israel had murdered this child and it
turns out the kid died of a blood
condition and then you wonder why no one
trusts the folks in the media is because
the media suck at their jobs stop
sucking air jobs and will trust you more
or when you get it wrong corrected
running with
blanket stories that are provided by
Hamas or running with stories about a
picture that isn't even based on reality
you know in which a mother put down her
kid for two minutes and the baby was
hungry and then the mother picked the
baby back up and then you take that
picture and you make it look like the
kid is crying about Donald Trump's
immigration policy no wonder we don't
trust you my favorite my favorite story
about lack of trust in the media today
comes courtesy of Politico so you know
that the media may be out to get you
when they start dredging up people you
went to third grade with I am not
kidding this is what Politico did today
Politico found some idiot named John
Muller okay John Muller who is the head
of a new Muller investigation he was
formerly a lecturer at Harvard Law
School which says very poor things about
my alma mater and he writes and studies
philosophy in Wisconsin he wrote a story
today quote I sat on the other side of
Stephen Miller's first wall Stephen
Miller of course is President Obama's
chief consultant when it comes to
immigration issues very close with Jeff
Sessions originally he was Jeff Jeff
Sessions his chief of staff before he
moved over to the Trump administration
proper this story is just insane so here
is a 900 word story in Politico by a guy
who went to third grade with Steve
Miller now you might think well maybe he
has something revelatory to tell us
about Stephen Miller maybe it turns out
that Stephen Miller in his off hours
killed puppies in the backyard
maybe Stephen Miller was the kind of kid
who tortured animals right like that
would actually be like a relevant story
but no that's not what the story is at
all
here's the story quote it was the year
he sat next to me in third grade it's
hard to say how much a kid's behavior
and third grade can really tell you
about the inner workings of his soul no
it's not hey third graders are idiots
okay they're their stupid little idiots
okay the idea that that's going to tell
you anything about the working of a
third grader stole again unless they are
torturing puppies or engaging in
pathological behavior there's it tells
you nothing okay third graders like pee
on themselves they smell like I love
kids
but let's not pretend that they're great
like I looked at you in third grade and
I knew from that moment that you were
destined to be the immigration leader in
the United States
okay No third grade was so stupid I
skipped it okay so here is the here is
what this idiot says surely the well
documented indicators of Miller's all
right beginnings in middle school high
school in college have less
impressionistic connections to his
current behavior but here is what I
remember I'm gonna read you the rest of
the story in a second because it is so
good and when I say it is so good I mean
it is so intensely stupid first
I want to say thanks to our sponsors
over at the u.s. ECA so you're a gun
lover which means it's time to listen up
did you enter to win your brand-new gun
from the US ECA yet look you're a
law-abiding Second Amendment loving
American citizen that means you should
be able to protect your family protect
your home protect your neighbors and the
u.s. ECA is gonna help you do that
right now you're about to miss the
deadline they're gonna Day Giveaway ends
really soon you can get up to 17 chances
to win your gun daily but only if you
act right now it could be 17 kimber 17
Glock 17 Springfield 17 ar-15s head over
to defend my family now calm to reveal
which gun you could be taking home today
and hurry because today's gun disappears
at midnight tonight the u.s. ECA wants
to get more guns into the hands of
responsibly armed Americans like you
that can help educate you about guns
they can help provide you the services
you need in case god forbid you actually
have to fire that gun at somebody they
are here to help train and protect the
protectors so don't put it off don't
miss your chance cover to defend my
family now calm because you could win a
new gun every single day again that is
defend my family now calm and remember
you have only until midnight tonight to
win today's gun tonight isn't that that
gun goes off the market it's a new gun
tomorrow defend my family now calm again
defend my family now calm us CCA does
wonderful work you should join them
regardless but right now you have the
added benefit of being able to answer to
win a gun which is pretty awesome defend
my family now calm go check it out okay
so back to this idiotic article from
from John Muller and his Muller
investigation it's the new Muller
investigation over Politico because it
about Stephen Miller being a third
grader because of our last name Stephen
and I shared a desk we are not friends
though he weren't exactly enemies either
our teacher miss Fisk had the class
write stories each week with vocabulary
words and sometimes she let us read them
aloud I wrote a series of stories about
a mixed-up chicken named Jeremy I am not
kidding this is in Politico I felt
proudest that year when I got to read my
stories in class and they made the other
kids laugh but it was difficult to make
Stephen laugh you understand truth is
what it says not joking it was difficult
to make see he wouldn't laugh at the
kids mixed up chicken stories this is
how he knew from the very beginning that
Stephen Miller wanted to imprison
illegal immigrants in Japanese
internment conditions I found him
difficult to reach at all and so it
seemed did most everyone else he was
frequently distracted vacillating
between total disinterest and everything
around him my stories of course included
this person's really pissed as Stephen
Miller didn't laugh at the mixed-up
chick of the stories my goodness
total disinterest and everything around
him my story's included this is a
highlight of his life these mixed up
chicken stories was all downhill from
the mixed-up chicken the stories about a
guy named Jeremy was a mixed-up chicken
and completely
why don't we trust the media I don't
understand and complete obsession with
highly specific tax that could protest
they could only be for performed alone
he was especially obsessed with tape and
glue again
this is in one of the most prestigious
political magazines in America along the
midpoint of our desks Stephen laid down
a piece of voice masking tape explaining
that it marked the boundary of our sides
and that I was not to cross it the
formality of this struck me as odd I was
a fairly neat kid at least at school and
I'd never spread my things to his side
of the desk Stephen meanwhile could not
have been much messier his side of the
desk was sticky and peeling littered
with scraps of paper misshapen erasers
and pencil nubs if there's adhesive
division kept Stephen on his side of the
desk I was all for it as unfriendly as
it seemed but instead the tape became an
attractive nuisance Stephen picked at it
with his fingernails methodically in a
mixture of absent-mindedness and what
seemed like channelled hostility you
could sense how much he hated Mexicans
by the way who's picking at the tape in
third grade on his desk unbelievable
this this guy's insight is just
incredible this process left and if this
process of a Faceman left a thin layer
of sticky grime not altogether
dissimilar from the rest of Stephens
desk he was grimy he was disgusting in
third grade
Stephen rubs his fingers over this layer
of grime rolling it into little gray
pellets until it too was gone then he
applied a new piece of tape along with a
renewed warning that I was not to cross
it don't rinse but do repeat for months
when Stephen was not picking at the tape
he was playing with glue dead serious
guys this is actually an article he
liked to pour it into his hands forming
grime tilted glaciers in the valleys of
his palms blues loosely in hand he
deployed his deepest powers of
concentration to watch these pools
harden the first sign would be a
rippling on the surface as if from a
winter Gale this reproduce a precarious
moment as Stephens urge to stick a
finger into the filmy layer became
palpable and his immobilized poem began
to tire okay I'm gonna continue with
this story in just a second first I just
have to say what the actual f tape
there's another 400 words with this
story it's not 400 words of this story
about Stephen Miller liking to play
liking to play with tape and glue
at age 8 hey again the Muller
investigation continues right this is
the actual Muller investigation John
Muller's investigation into his time in
third grade with Stephen Miller quote
invariably Stephen succumbed to this
urge before the glue fully hardened at
which point the prior game transformed
into a new one the game of spreading
still viscous glue crossed the remainder
of his hand then once the glue dried he
picked it off into long strips the glue
pulling the skin on his palm outward as
he tugged it with his other hand with
skin snapping back into place when each
strip broke off still the sticky
adhesive beneath the strips of glue
remained on his palm so Stephen rubbed
his hands together to produce more
little gray pellets which he collected
and rolled together into a mound this in
turn was used to blot at and thereby
clean or perhaps dirty his portion of
the desk
okay now you may be thinking okay well
so where's like the actual meet Uncle
Eddie like where does he where's the
actual meat of the story when do we get
to the part where Stephen out and when
Stephen Miller like kills cats in the
backyard look where we get that for
better or worse is the full extent of my
memory of Stephen that year at Franklin
Elementary School in Santa Monica
California where the sign out front
reads be a friend not a bully oh the
irony
the irony an elementary school has a
sign that says be a friend not a bully
but Stephen Miller turned out to be the
world's worst frontally balding bully
it's just it's unbelievable I heard
stories about him from friends as we got
older but I wasn't around to witness
things firsthand I switched to a
different school after sixth grade what
to make of this now 25 years later we
were all grimy kids at some point of
course with sticky hands and short
attention spans but it is at least
poetic that Stephen was bent on building
a nonsensical wall even back then a wall
that had more to do with what lay inside
him than what lay beyond
he thought he was trying to keep out the
chaos of the world when really what he
was looking for was a way to explain
away the chaos on his own side of the
desk for that was where chaos had always
been that's an actual article in Poetica
ok that's think that's really that's it
now we won't find out until later that
the Moller investigation will end with
an actual P tape of Stephen Miller you
know peeing his pants in third grade but
it's just amazing like why don't people
trust the media I don't understand why
wouldn't we trust people who decide the
DAT is print worthy the National
quire wouldn't pay five cents for that
piece but Politico somehow thought you
know what what people deeply need to
what it's deeply important people must
know people must know that Stephen
Miller once took a piece of tape and put
it across the sensor of his desk when he
was 8 years old and then removed that
piece of tape and he liked to put glue
on his hands and take it off just like
every other third grader in the history
of the world since Elmer glue was
invented no it's just yes that but why
don't people trust him yet I don't know
I don't know it must be it it's Trump
its Trump Trump is so evil help that's
all at the table got that's all I've got
I try I trust the media more now because
I've read that story because now I know
that deep in the recesses of Stephen
Miller's mind is the little boy that
grimy little evil child who like to take
eraser nubs and stack them on his desk
who chewed on pencils who like to go
over and grind his pencils those giant
pencils that fit in the palm of your
hand in that little in that little
pencil sharpener that you used to
actually have to hand grind like some
sort of organ Oh Stephen Miller maybe I
love you never changed media never
change speaking of stupid things in the
media so yesterday everyone went nuts
because Melania Trump wore a jacket okay
I don't know what timeline we fell in to
you guys but it is the stupidest
timeline wait I don't know what we
everyday we stray further from God's
light so Melania Trump went to visit a
bunch of child refugees or illegal
immigrant children along the border and
before she got on her plane and on the
East Coast in Bethesda Maryland
before she got on her plane she wore
this jacket it's a jacket from Zara that
is $39 and it says I really don't care
do you on the back of it suffice it to
say this is not a smart move this is not
a smart thing to do right because you're
trying to go and demonstrate how much
you do care and now you're wearing a
jacket that says I really don't care do
you I will explain though whether I care
a lot about this jacket in just one
second first I want to talk to you about
clothing that you really should wear and
that of course is a tailored suit from
Enzo chinos so you always look better in
a custom tailored suit not in a $39
jacket from Zara's that says
really don't care to you like an actual
tailored suit that looks great on you
and that would be fit for a king this is
why you should go over to Indo Chino
comm they're the world's largest
made-to-measure menswear company they've
been featured in major publications
including GQ Forbes and Fast Company
they make suits and shirts made your
exact measurements for a great fit guys
love the wide selection of high quality
fabrics and the option to personalize
all the details including lapel lining
and monogram you can go over to one of
their stores I went to one over in Santa
Monica it's really a lot of fun you can
look at all the fabrics and they can
help you choose all your customizations
and then you you get it in the mail
right they send it to you and it fits
like a glove and if it doesn't they fix
it for you this week my listeners can
get any premium Indo Chino suit for just
379 bucks at Indo Chino calm when
entering Shapiro's at checkout you don't
have to go to one of their stores by the
way you can do it online and send in all
your measurements they send the suit
directly to you that's 50% off the
regular price for a major measure
premium suit 379 bucks for any premium
Indo Chino suit that's Indo Chino calm
when you enter promo code Shapiro's at
checkout shipping is free Indo Chino com
promo code Shapiro for any premium suit
for just 379 bucks and free shipping
that's the suit that you're gonna want
it's a suit that you're going to wear
it's pretty is pretty great okay so
Melania Trump yesterday wears this
jacket this I really don't care do you
jacket now obviously she meant to wear
the jacket there's a lot of talk say oh
it's just she didn't really mean to wear
the jacket like you she just sort of put
on a jacket Melania Trump wearing a $39
jacket the last time Melania Trump were
something that inexpensive she was naked
on the cover of the New York Post okay
like she has like Melania Trump has
never worn something that cost $39 like
legitimately her pinky rings cost $39
right the ankle bracelets that she does
or does not wear right those cost $39 so
her $39 jacket that said I really don't
care to you and so this became the
mystery the media had to solve yesterday
why did she wear this why it's a
Stephanie Gresham who is her
spokesperson over the White House
tweeted out today's visit with the
children in Texas impacted FLOTUS
greatly if media would spend their time
and energy on her actions and efforts to
help kids rather than speculate and
focus on her wardrobe she would get so
much accomplished on behalf of children
hash tag she cares hash tag it's just a
jacket yeah well listen Melania Trump
knows what she's wearing
and the hilarious part of this is that
Trump then responds and Trump jumps into
the fray so Trump feels that he needs to
to discuss Melania Trump's where he is
just that he has to jump into
this is so funny so Trump everything is
so stupid man it's so dumb
Trump tweets out quote they really don't
care to you written on the back of
milania's jacket refers to the fake news
media Melania has learned how to sinus
they are and she truly no longer cares
so her own spokespersons like you
shouldn't focus in on the jack and
Trump's like screw the media it's it's
so great it's so great in every way now
does this mean that Melania doesn't care
no it just means that someone was dumb
and allowing her to wear that or she was
dumb and picking that like that it's
just stupid right you don't wear a
jacket like that when you're about to go
visit refugees it's not the brightest
move this is the part where Melania I
should say that her command of the
English language is not that great right
that would be that'd be the proper
defense here or she didn't see the back
of the jacket she turned it inside out
or something but like that like no is it
a big deal no do the media go nuts over
it yesterday of course is it bad optics
absolutely is it dumb on every level you
bet but everything is dumb on every
level right now everything is incredibly
stupid on every level which is too bad
because there's some pretty serious
issues that are happening here right
some of the things that are happening
here actually matter right the policy
with regard to our border actually
matters now president Trump has it right
when he rips into Democrats when he says
listen what you really want is to
release as many illegal immigrants as
humanly possible Cynthia Nixon proved
this yesterday so Cynthia Nixon you
recall her from being the most
irritating member of the cast in Sex in
the City which says a lot I mean you
really have to work to be the most
irritating member of the cast in Sex in
the City but Cynthia Nixon is now
running for governor of New York she
will lose horribly to to Andrew Cuomo of
course but she says that her program is
that she definitely definitely wants to
abolish ice right no borders
so when Trump says the Democrats don't
want borders and then the media says
that's a lie
um Cynthia Nixon pretty much just said
out loud what you're not supposed to say
out loud they're being separated
throughout this country by a nice yes I
think we need to abolish ice that seems
really clear they have strayed so far
from the interests of the American
people and the interests of humanity we
need to we need to abolish it okay oh
and in your solution to people crossing
the border illegally would be what and
the answer is the board the solution may
just let people cross the border
illegally so when President Trump rips
into Democrats he is not wrong about
this here is Trump yesterday saying
Democrats are by not deterring border
crossing they're creating a child
smuggling industry there is some truth
to this people are suffering because of
the Democrats
so we've created and they've created and
they've let it happen
a massive child smuggling industry
that's exactly what it's become
okay I do like how President Trump
announces industry industry it's he does
it just to piss people off I think but
he's exactly right here and he's also
right when he says listen the media have
been complaining about the inhumane
treatment of children well what about
the inhumane treatment of children under
Obama now there was some attention paid
to this in 2014-2015 but it wasn't on
the cover of Time magazine
Obama frowning down at a crying child
wrapped in aluminum foil blankets here
was President Trump going off on the
media you look back at 2014 during the
Obama administration they have pictures
that were so bad they had a judge that
said it was inhumane the way they were
treating children take a look at some of
the court rulings against the Obama
administration they talked about
inhumane treatment I read them I looked
at him they were all over the place
inhumane treatment they were treating
him terribly
okay he's totally right about this now
the left is of course responded by
saying that Trump is a uniquely evil
individual Cory Booker who is just the
most I mean if Cynthia Nixon was the
most irritating member of the Sex in the
City cast Cory Booker is the most
irritating person in the United States
in politics when Cory Booker and his
virtue signaling he is just awful in
every way you remember when he started
shouting at who was it that he was
shouting at in his in his it was a
Kirsten Neilson makes perfect sense
he was shouting at her and now he is now
he is saying this is moral vandalism of
our values I love how everything that
cory booker says was written by Aaron
Sorkin here is Cory Booker we just have
to do this and stop doing this moral
vandalism on our values that you see is
going on that's just fun acceptable and
it's barely English but I guess the
point is clear its moral vandalism about
and then Nancy Pelosi a woman who is for
aborting babies pretty much until your
you actually die as a full human being
like Nancy Pelosi is so pro-abortion if
you're 78 you've been born for 78 years
she still thinks that there's a question
is whether your mom should be able to
abort you Nancy Pelosi
she says this right here is outside the
circle of human behavior it's outside
the circle of human behavior dentures
are quacking around go for Nancy the
president is
either not knowing not caring delusional
and denial about his own policies being
beat outside the circle of civilized
human behavior he's a monster do you
understand he's an absolute monster
and then then here's here's the here's
the hard part for Democrats jeh Johnson
you remember that guy he's the
Department of Homeland Security
secretary under the Obama administration
he's sort of admitted that in 2014 they
expanded family detention oops
when 2014 to deal with the spike then
with the families we did a number of
things including by the way working with
the government of Mexico and obtaining
their cooperation on securing their
southern border but we also expanded
family detention which was I freely
admit controversial oops
oopsies so it turns out that all of
trumps evil mattias policies well it
turns out the reason that they are so
evil and Nazi ask is because the Obama
administration was keeping families
together in detention and then a court
said you have to separate the families
and then Trump abided by the court
ruling and now Trump is is trying to
reverse the court ruling to go back to
the Obama administration policy and he's
getting ripped every step of the way so
in other words he follows the Ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals he's evil
he follows Jay Johnson he's evil it
seems to me that maybe the Democrats
program here is just a call from people
they don't actually care about these
kids particularly much so that's that is
just ridiculous okay so in just a few
minutes I want to go into the mailbag
and in a few minutes and then we have
some stuff I like and stuff I hate
coming up and I have many things that I
hate and many questions in the mailbag
so the show will be replete with content
in just a moment but first we're gonna
have to go over to Daily wire comm and
subscribe $9.99 a month gets you
subscription to this show it helps us
bring you the show every single day it
also ensures they get the michael Mol's
show and the Andrew Clavin show if those
are things that you actually want and
you get to be part of the mailbag right
we have the mailbag today you want to
ask questions well today is your chance
you get to ask your question and I will
answer those questions for you and make
your life all that much better plus when
you get the annual subscription you get
this the very greatest in beverage
vessels he left his tears hot or cold
tumblr also when you are a subscriber
you get first crack at our VIP ticket so
if you actually want to meet
face-to-face and bask in my glory then
all you have to do is become a
subscriber and then get the VIP tickets
when we have events in Dallas and
Phoenix over at Daily wire comm slash
events also please subscribe in our
youtube channel it really helps us when
you subscribe to our youtube channel if
you listen
don't just listen go very YouTube
channel and subscribe that's because we
have great things like video of the
Sunday special right this week we have
Jason Whitlock on the Sunday special it
is a great conversation about sports in
the NFL and the implications for culture
in our politics it's a great
conversation you can check that out we
are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so I'm gonna jump right into
the mailbag so let's get into it all
right
Kiran says I've recently been labeled
alt-right on a very public forum by a
notoriously pretentious SJW my views are
countercultural for a 21 year old woman
considering I'm a lifelong conservative
but I am nowhere near alright I am
apparently anti-feminist only third wave
racist because I wouldn't announce
you're Arabs in open sewage tweet after
recommending your show to set sjw and
opposed to all immigration face poem my
parents were immigrants and a white
nationalist which is so far from truth I
didn't even know how to begin
entertaining the debate let alone his BS
how do i combat claims like this or
argue with a liberal about anything
without stooping intellectually thank
you for your brain well thank me for my
brain thank God for my brain I didn't
make it but as far as but as far as how
you argue all of this stuff first of all
I just like to note that that tweet that
you reference in that email Karen I
wrote an entire column explaining that
tweet and they're a bunch of follow-up
suites that explain that tweet this is
like 2010 circa 2010 so just to give a
little context for that but beyond that
the reality is that not every arguments
worth having I'm being being labeled in
an outright personality by an idiot sjw
on a public forum you should make your
statement you should let it go at that
and then you shouldn't waste more of
your time because the person's never
going to admit they were wrong you
should determine in every conversation
what the purpose of the conversation is
it works by the way in real life as well
like I try to determine whether a
conversation is worthwhile here in the
office which is why I rarely deign to
speak to those around me I mean Jamie
come on very very few of these
conversations are worth it but even when
it comes to when it comes to my marriage
my wife and I have a great rule that I
love and that is tips dudes okay tip to
tip to the guys out there who are dating
ladies or married to ladies if you are
having a conversation with your wife or
your girlfriend and she starts
complaining to you about a particular
situation in her life your first
tendency is going to be to try and solve
the problem for her this is probably not
what she wants but she probably wants is
for you to listen now I know you don't
want to listen I get it but the way to
solve this problem is to say is this a
solving is this a solving conversation
or a listening conversation and if you
say that then you know the purpose of
the conversation if you can apply that
same sort of logic to all of your
interactions particularly political
interactions you'll be a lot better off
not every conversation is worth having
Joel says Ben even though
environmentalists are radical their
movements lead to better tech like LEDs
electric cars and biodegradable
materials can there be benefit
beneficial effects
radical movements well sure I mean I
think there are a lot of radical
movements that have had beneficial
effects even if their overall effect is
a net negative I would suggest that that
you know the the idea that efficient
vehicles were an outgrowth of the
environmental movement I don't think is
exactly correct I think that efficient
vehicles were an outgrowth of high gas
prices in the 1970s and the fact that
nobody wanted a clunker when there were
going to be all of these escalating gas
prices thanks to OPEC choking off the
oil supply this is why you see bigger
cars on the road when gas prices are
cheaper and smaller cars on the road
when gas prices get more expensive with
that said because the truth is that
environmentalism the only way that
environmentalism can really make LED
lights for example more fiscally
feasible is by artificially raising the
price of incandescent light bulbs I kind
of like incandescent lightbulbs to tell
you the truth but you know I I do
appreciate that radical movements if you
channel all of your efforts toward one
particular end sometimes you'll come up
with a few good good effects it's not
like everything that is associated with
a movement I consider bad as bad
sometimes they're good outgrowths right
the fact is that there are a lot of
vaccines that were developed originally
from an aborted fetus right that doesn't
mean that the abortion originally was
good but to ignore that the vaccines are
useful would be to deny science okay
aerials is hey Ben for the big fan I
could really use your advice I'm
volunteering at a day camp next week I
was told that one of the girls I'll be
working with consider herself a boy
sometimes depending on the day well
that's great she's five how do I
interact with her so I just go along
humor her as I would if she was
pretending to be a fairy princess or a
unicorn or say something most likely
after this camp program is over I won't
see her again thanks for any advice well
I mean it depends Arielle do you want to
keep your job I mean really this is a
priorities question because the reality
is I think that it is unhealthy to humor
the delusions of small children I do not
think that it is healthy if a
five-year-old claims something that is
factually untrue I don't think the
humoring that is is worthwhile or good
my kids claim things that are untrue all
the time and it is my job to disabuse
them of those notions
doesn't mean have to be rude or terrible
but you have to check in with the camp
because it's possible that the camp
doesn't want to get sued or that you
will be fired so it really depends on
and if you're uncomfortable with this
situation maybe you ask to be you know
moved out of this situation maybe you
ask to to counsel other kids for example
or you have when your colleagues take
over with regard to to this kit because
you feel the too moral to abide by the
rules that are set by the camp but as a
general man
I think it's immoral to treat
five-year-olds with great respect when
they say things that are that are
actually delusional and humoring
delusion is not good for kids
fully 80% of kids who have transgender
feelings grow out of it by the time they
reach young adulthood Scott says hey
Ben's you ever feel guilty about the
abuse you lay upon Knolls if not have
you provided him a safe space away from
the daily torment you inflict on him no
I've never felt guilty about the abuse
that you lay upon Knowles just as I
would never feel guilty about the abuse
that I land on Pol Pot or kim jeong-hoon
I mean they're just certain people who
deserve abuse and knowles is one of them
and by the way I pay knowles okay so for
all the abuse that I that I lay on
Knowles he ain't to worry about cashing
the paycheck apparently as far as the
safe space that is provided for him he
does have a small office off the main
hall here and we lock him in there we
have patted the walls so that he can
really have himself a good time in there
all right Brandon says hey Ben do you
think that religion as a whole could
experience a resurrection similar to
that of Christ in Bible or our religious
and communal groups doomed to decline in
the years to come I do think that
religion as a whole is going to
experience a resurrection and I think
that that is going to happen
specifically because there's a great
crisis of meaning that is happening in
the West people believe that their lives
are purposeless they believe that there
is no actual goal to their life there's
no Tilos there's no Greek teleology to
their life and there's also no religious
nature to their life and so we are
bogging ourselves down in hedonism and
political anger and partisanship and
it's leading to a worse America and it's
leading to worse interpersonal
relationships so I do think there's
going to be a religious revival in the
country because I think there's
religious instinct in people that has
been forcibly removed from them by a
secularist Society and I think that
that's a serious problem there will be a
backlash Jeremy says what is your take
on Milton Friedman's negative income tax
it's not something I've heard you
address him above your take on it so
Milton Friedman egg Milton Friedman's
negative income tax for people who don't
know is basically his suggestion that we
cut checks back to people who are poor
enough that they don't pay income tax
and his suggestion is that this should
replace the welfare system as a
replacement for the welfare system I
would much prefer a negative income tax
to the welfare system itself because the
welfare system is quasi means-tested not
really it's too complex it
disincentivizes good responsible
behavior the negative income tax
basically signs you a certain amounts of
money based on the amount of money that
you are making to bring you up to a
certain average amounts of money it
makes a lot more sense
Nolan Freeman's negative income tax than
the welfare system but any sort of
government redistribution system
going to be subject to corruption and
political interplay which is why in the
end I prefer private charity and local
government as opposed to a federal
negative income tax for example NOAA
says hey then a few weeks ago you said
something about the Establishment Clause
of the First Amendment they got me
curious what is your take on the effort
to remove God from the pledge currency
etc is invoking the name of God and
government not a violation of the
Establishment Clause I'd love to hear
your opinion it's not a violation of the
Establishment Clause specifically
because the Establishment Clause was
designed to prevent the imposition of a
specific religion on any human being so
if for example it was mandatory from the
government that you use God every time
you went out in public or that it was
mandatory that you say under God in the
Pledge of Allegiance or that it was
mandatory you stand for god Bless
America or that it was mandatory put
your hand over her anything that
mandates the worship God is against the
Establishment Clause there's nothing in
the Establishment Clause however that
says that government cannot prefer in
general a religious outlook on life to a
non-religious outlook on life there's
nothing in the Constitution that
suggests this in fact if you go back to
the original founding of the country
obviously there are prayers that were
being given by by people on a regular
basis in the halls of Congress George
Washington regularly prayed he gave
prayers at his inaugural address the it
is also worth mentioning that there were
a bunch of states in the United States
the Establishment Clause this is
something people don't know about the
Federal Constitution the Federal
Constitution originally did not apply to
the States
so there's an Establishment Clause
clause that says Congress shall make no
law abridging freedom of speech or
establishing religion okay that's
Congress shall make no law it applied to
the federal Congress there were states
in the United States that actually had
quasi official religions okay at the
very beginning of the Republic and then
over time that sort of drained away I
think it was a good thing that drained
away but it obviously the Federal
Constitution did not bar even
state-sponsored religion like specific
sects of religion in particular states
in the United States originally so no
the Establishment Clause does not
prevent you from saying we trust in God
on our coins or something and if you
really feel that badly about it saying
we trust in God on our coins then I
suggest that you investigate American
history in which God has played a pretty
significant role Cassandra says is there
a historical figure or event that film
has not covered or covered well they
would like to see developed into a movie
if so who or what would you like to see
directed oh there's so many of them so I
think there's a great movie or
miniseries to be made about John Brown
just because there's so much moral
complex
with regard to John Brown so John Brown
is if you remember from your Civil War
history John Brown was a guy who was
involved in something called Bleeding
Kansas originally in 1856 1857 there
something called Bleeding Kansas in 1854
1856 basically what happened is that
there was a bill in Congress they called
the kansas-nebraska Act and it suggested
that in that Kansas Nebraska were going
to be admitted as states to the Union
and the way that these states were going
to be admitted as either free states or
slave states is there was gonna be a
referendum held in these states as to
whether the states ought to be slave
states or free states and what that led
to was an enormous number of people
rushing into these states in order so
that they could vote specifically on the
issue of slavery well John Brown and his
sons went to Kansas and they they're
engaged in acts of brutal violence
against slaveholders who are also
engaging in brutal acts of violence
against people who are in favor of the
freedom of the states okay so he's
involved in that and then John Brown of
course took a bunch of his sons and and
some former slaves some ex ladies and he
went to Harpers Ferry Virginia and he
freed a bunch of slaves he thought who's
gonna lead a slave uprising against
labor holders in Harpers Ferry Harpers
Ferry Virginia and there he instead was
basically surrounded in a in a bunkhouse
basically his sons were shot to death
the other people who were fighting with
him were shot to death
couple of slaveholders were murdered as
well and and John Brown eventually was
hung or he was hanged rather and it's a
really fascinating story the actual
commander of the Union forces at Harpers
Ferry was a guy that you may remember by
the name of robert e lee so it's really
historically repeated it's really
fascinating stuff and as the soldiers in
the Civil War went to went to battle
they actually sang the song that the
original lyrics to the the Battle Hymn
of the Republic you know glory glory
hallelujah that the original lyrics to
that to that song were not were not what
they eventually became they originally
the song was called John Brown's body
and the original lyric was John Brown's
body is a mold Rijn in his tomb John
Brown's body is Mulder and in his tomb
John Brown's bodies and moldering in his
tomb his soul his truth goes marching on
it was about John Brown was an actual
rebel who killed people right trying to
free slaves fascinating fascinating
stuff about you know when is sort of
zealous violence necessary was it
necessary in this particular case really
interesting stuff the other one is a
great question so I have another one
that I love I really want somebody to
make a full-scale dramatic fill
about the Frazier Ali fights there's a
great documentary that I've recommended
before it's an HBO documentary about the
Frazier Ali fights
called ghost of middle that's quite good
there's a book about it as well that's
really good but it's Joe Frazier's tale
as well we're telling because he was a
guy who grew up in Philadelphia
dirt-poor
right Rocky Mount Rocky's character in
Rocky is actually based in part on Joe
Lewis on a Joe Frazier rather grew up in
Philadelphia dirt-poor
Muhammad Ali grew up middle class in
Louisiana and Joe Frazier gave Muhammad
Ali a fight right Muhammad Ali was
banned from fighting for a cut for
several years and when he wanted to come
back Joe Frazier gave him if I didn't
have to at that point Joe Frazier was an
undefeated heavyweight champion he'd
have to give him Hamid Lee a fight he
gave him a fight he encouraged Muhammad
Ali's ban to be removed so he could
fight and then he beat him in the first
fight but Muhammad Ali used that fight
as a weapon against Joe Frazier so he
would go out in public and he started
calling Joe Frazier a gorilla and he
suggested that Joe Frazier was a sellout
and that Joe Frazier because Joe Frazier
was very Pro America that Joe Frazier
was a bad guy and the entire black
community or at least large segments of
it swung behind Muhammad Ali and against
Joe Frazier who five minutes before had
had been a hero to many members of the
black community it was a real culture
war and that cultural war extended all
the way through the third Frazier Ali
fight in which the Thrilla in Manilla in
which Frazier and Ali basically went to
war they both almost died on the canvas
and Frazier really I mean he said he
wanted to kill all the in the ring
because he was so angry with Holly for
having destroyed his legacy and for
having contributed to his unpopularity
in the black community it's really
fascinating Lee was supposed to make a
movie about all of us and angley did did
not end up doing it I'm trying I think
like this would make a good it wouldn't
be along the lines what he normally does
but I think that Peter Weir could do a
really good job with something like this
the guy who did Master and Commander and
as far as the the Harpers Ferry story
the John Brown story Christopher Nolan
would do an amazing bang-up job with
that because he could do all sorts of
flashbacks in time stuff would be really
interesting okay so let's see i knowa
says oh where did not okay Thomas says
hello from the Republic of Korea what
are your thoughts on the developments of
space force a worthy endeavor or a waste
of taxpayer money thank you for bringing
reason to politics and for all that you
do sincerely Thomas well first of all I
just love that there is now a space
force and I hope that I just hope that
we can ship
crates up to space force that's all I
really want in life
so first of all I think all the ads
should be cut from Starship Troopers
it'll be just fantastic and I love that
Donald Trump is so into space for so
well isn't it I like it I'm I'll admit
I'm fond of space force I think that
there will be battles in space
eventually and if there aren't then
we've all been shortchanged by the
movies for the last 30 years so I'm okay
with with the idea that the United
States should be investigating how we
defend ourselves from threats that our
that our space imminent Plus how else
are we going to ensure that that if
there's an asteroid hurtling toward
Earth that we can prevent it I mean are
we gonna send Bruce Willis up there with
Ben Affleck and if so why exactly why
exactly would Bruce Willis die to save
Ben Affleck why okay that's the real
question there who wants to save Ben
Affleck in any circumstance and why
would Bruce Willis do so foolish foolish
move Bruce Willis don't worry Liv Tyler
will get over it but you know oh well
Andrew says hi Ben I was wondering what
your opinion on the CIA intervention in
Latin America is I hear many claims
about how this was true imperialism of
the United States even that it should be
justified for affirmative action and
open borders for people from those
countries was the u.s. profits or to
save Central and South America from the
horror of Marxism it was to save Central
and South America from the horror of
Marxism akin Sandinistas were evil okay
the Sandinistas the Marxist and zani
says they were bad people the Nicaraguan
send in Anthony says there were Marxist
movements that emerged slaughtered
literally tens of thousands of people in
these areas
does that mean that all the people the
United States sided with in those
conflicts were wonderful human beings no
it doesn't but it also happens to be
true that the dictatorships that existed
in those regions pretty in relatively
short order you know speaking in terms
of global timelines devolves into
something much more closely resembling
Western democracy than states that fell
to - Marx his tyranny Marxism is a great
great evil and backing freedom movements
against marxist tyranny seems to me
worthwhile and even backing bad guys
against Marxist movements very often
ends up being worthwhile in the shorter
run than it would be if you've got a
Marxist regime running a place I mean
Cuba's still being run in Marxist
fashion so it's North Korea Bailey says
hi Ben with the rise of the Trump wing
of the Republican Party with the ever
growing extremism of the Democratic
Party do you see the possibility of the
American political scene moving beyond a
two-party system not the way that's
built so the fact that we have a first
pass the pole system in
in terms of how our elections work tends
to bias toward a two-party system
because two people are usually going to
be near the top of the list and that
means that if it's the first person
passed that pole wins whoever has the
most money in most infrastructure as
likely to have benefit michael says hey
ben i'm a fan of the show i know there's
been a lot of criticism from the right
and from President Trump on Jeff
sessions since he became AG so my
question is what would be a great for AG
session so far thanks Michael
I like Ag sessions I think sessions has
done a pretty good job I think that
sessions is an honest guy I disagree
with him about the drug war I think that
his is you know his words about
marijuana I don't agree with on a
scientific basis but I think that as a
guy who's trying to enforce the line in
honest fashion I don't understand the
hatred for Jeff Sessions I think that
he's doing his best and he's trying to
be an honest broker I know that a lot of
people very angry at sessions for not
protecting Trump in the way that Eric
Holder protected Barack Obama but that's
because Eric Holder was not supposed to
do that that's not the job of the AG and
I think that it's too bad that people
now think that all of these areas of
government ought to be weaponized
because the other side has weaponized
them okay time for some things I like
and then some things that I hate so
things that I like yesterday I did a
Dvorak piano quintet so sticking with
the Dvorak theme I mentioned this
yesterday on the show the second
movement of his New World Symphony is
very famous you'll recognize it probably
when I play it but it is a magnificent
piece the symphony number nine and C
minor the the New World Symphony is one
of the great pieces in the Western canon
it is just fantastic and the second
movement is just heartbreakingly
beautiful
[Music]
it's just amazing music and yeah check
that out and say when people ask me you
know what's a good piece for the
introduction on people who don't like
classical music into classical music
this is a great piece to recommend the
New World Symphony from beginning to end
it's just terrific okay time for a
couple of things that I hate so the
first thing that I hate is you know kind
of in line with that music Charles
Krauthammer passed away yesterday so
Charles Krauthammer died truly I think
the thought leader for an entire
generation of people who are growing up
on on political commentary when I say
that I grew up reading Charles
Krauthammer I don't mean just that I
grew up reading Charles Krauthammer as
and I got older I mean that Charles
Krauthammer helps you grow up when you
read Charles Krauthammer
you realize this is a person who
examined all sides of issues he was a
nuanced writer and a nuanced thinker he
was somebody who really deeply thought
about things one of the things that was
interesting about Krauthammer that I
happen to know he's now Krauthammer was
not all that much into the daily
headlines I remember the first time that
I met him was in his offices in
Washington DC along with some colleagues
from Breitbart where I was working at
that point and he was really not up on
the day's news which I thought was
really weird because he was on Fox News
like every day and then I realized that
the reason he wasn't up on the day's
news is because Charles spent so much
time reading about deep philosophies and
ideas he was much more focused on sort
of the the rock bed underneath the ocean
that he was worried about the ripples on
the daily surface of politics more than
that he was not tribal in any sense this
is a guy who was an independent thinker
he had interesting ideas on a variety of
subjects he was an animal rights guy for
one at the same time that he was against
stem-cell research fetal stem cell
research even though he himself was of
course a paraplegic from that from the
chest down he's just an amazing human
being I talked about him a little bit
when it was announced that he was going
to pass away he's somebody who I wanted
to emulate when you're younger you want
to be a provocateur right when you're
when you're 17 18 years old you think
that the way you're gonna make your way
in politics is by saying provocative
things you know things that get the
headline things that get the click I get
it I was there if you read my early
writing it's a lot more provocateur ish
and as you get older you realize it's
less worthwhile to be a provocateur and
more worthwhile to try and be like
Charles Krauthammer Krauthammer was also
a real craftsman of the word he's
somebody who really spent time on his
writing and you can read it I mean his
he had a real gift for making hard work
seem as though as easily written if you
read his stuff it feels like this is so
natural
to read but apparently he went over
every column that you ever wrote
something like 15 times and you always
got the impression that he'd thought
things through I remember you know if
you didn't know what to think on an
issue he was somebody who you always
read and even if you disagreed with him
he was somebody who was making a great
argument he was also deeply
intellectually curious I remember the
second I only met him twice the second
time that I met him I met him over at
the Prague revue offices this is
probably just a year ago and he was
doing a video for pregger you about
building the wall actually suggesting
that President Trump was right when he
said that we ought to build a wall on
the southern border of the United States
and I was talking with him a little bit
and we were talking about
I guess health care was in the news at
that point and he asked me the
distinction between the Australian
health care system the Canadian health
care system now both are nationalized
health care systems and there are some
minor nuances to them that are that are
different like in Canada its universal
health care from top to bottom in
Australia you are basically supposed to
you're incentivized to buy a private
health care plan but you know I will say
that I felt insufficient in my answers
and I remember coming away thinking was
he grilling me like was he testing me
and then I realized he wasn't grilling
me or test me he actually wanted to know
and that was the thing about Krauthammer
he always wanted to know from a lot of
people who knew him a lot better
knighted this is a guy whose insatiably
curious intellectually and you know when
he passed away before he passed away he
put out a statement where he said I
leave this life with no regrets it was a
wonderful life full and complete with
the great loves and great endeavors that
make it worth living I'm sad to leave
but I leave with the knowledge that I
lived the life that I intended you can't
ask for more than that you can't ask for
more than that and maybe we all feel
that way when we go so I rely on high
met who's Jewish guy and that just means
blessed is the true judge in Hebrew we
always say that when somebody dies and
you know I think that his work is going
to live on and the Washington Nationals
didn't ice tributes hit me last night he
was a huge baseball fan in the
Washington Nationals held a moment of
silence for him last night which was
just right okay so final thing that I
hate today and then we will break for
the weekend so I have to say do not
people who get deeply invested in
politicians I can't I can't go there I
can't go there politicians are just like
a plumber they're people who have a job
and if you get that deeply invested in
politicians as the avatar of your
emotions and the avatar of your feelings
and the avatar of your values I think
you're making a big mistake we should we
should be invested in members of your
family be invested in people you know be
invested in people not telling lies but
when you get deeply invested in like the
personal travail
of a particular political figure I think
that we're verging on something that's
not great so here's some video of some
Trump supporters at a recent rally and
as I mean I started to show today by
saying the media have been lying
routinely about President Trump so this
is not about the media not lying about
Trump they do lie about Trump on a
routine basis but the sort of emotional
response that people have the President
Trump I was true of Obama to on the Left
I don't think it's healthy for any
political leader family means a lot to
us so we have to do it I see you getting
emotional why is that because
he tried so hard and some people I don't
know or not um you know listen I
understand you're emotionally invested
in politics but president Trump can
handle it okay he's a tough guys big
strong guy president Trump has taken a
lot of slings and arrows he'll be fine
we should not be so invested in our
political leaders that we start to get
emotional about what a what great men
how could they possibly be that's the
game that's the nature of the game you
get in the game that's the way the game
works
it is like crying every time a your
favorite quarterback gets sacked
that's part of the game you may be upset
that he got sacked but you know this is
this part of the acceptable risk of the
game and I think that we all ought to be
a little more tough minded about our
boehm politicians on any side of the
aisle okay well we will be back here on
Monday with all the latest I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire Ford
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018